what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today
so excited we're gonna watch loki
episode five
let the loki vary it's inter act amongst
each other there's actually a reshot
intro for stupid reasons i don't need to
tell you about but guys
here's what i said before if you end up
enjoying this video i would really
appreciate it
if you could hit the like button
that's the first thing i said the second
thing i said was if you
enjoyed this video subscribe and click
that notification bell also
full length watch along is where you
sync up with the time code are over
at our patreon page we cover a bunch of
other shows there too like i mentioned
all the time
however the new tradition must continue
another reaction channel i would like to
shout out and this one
is going to be the movie couple it stars
wendy and dustin dustin were very close
what do we don't really know what you
know what it was funnier the first time
i said it but they're not going to see
that
they're not going to see it but you
could just explain that it was not
always
because the joke is that we're actually
really we know when you're better than
dustin but dustin's great too
yeah anyway guys look what i said before
is that wendy
is uh an amazing human being like
ever since this whole time of doing
youtube she has been one of the most
absolute
genuine helpful human beings i've ever
gotten to know she's just a real friend
so it was dustin by association because
we're closer to you i love you justin
and i love dustin too
you know it's just let's face it who am
i going to text they have a reaction
channel the movie couple where
they're killing it they're hustling
constantly and uh they're very
entertaining reactions and they're just
great people overall
everything doll thank you for hustling
getting this video up for us getting
them highlights done let's do this
there's some strong coarse language in
this episode
according to the rating maybe we can get
a marvel f bomb
tva is turning upside down man the whole
world's turning upside down
i love this shot both of us madness i
love the whole
episode because i love this one shot so
it's a great shot
don't know what it could be symbolizing
though
is anyone else excited right now
look at this this is awesome i think i'm
gonna call nipple chills before you do
oh what did that building say darn it is
one of those the daily bugle
oh wow great establishing shot showing
you the world that are in is it the void
that's a life
and where his lunch come on
awesome
[Music]
that's the original design of clifford
the big red dog
you thought the realistic red shade was
scary so they have to kill goliath
who's really behind the tva i'm as in
the dark as you are
i want to know who lied to me
i don't believe you branched reality
it's impossible to destroy all its
matter
so we move it to a place on the timeline
where it won't continue growing
a garbage dimension yes nothing ever
comes back from there
i can help you if you trust me
how can she trust you yeah i still don't
trust you
yeah let's put one of those like
collar things on her yeah yeah that's a
good idea
get p15 in here
wow i'd suggest we take a quick breather
so i can ask several thousand questions
well someone please explain to me what
the hell is going on
that's a strong course language whoa
this is disney
families and now i'm surrounded by
variants of myself
plus an alligator which i'm heartbroken
to report i didn't even find all that
strange
way back to the tva
stop filing or you signal alliance you
mean the monster in the sky
oh you cool loki you're not kid loki
cool loki with a k elias he ensures none
of it ever returns and just like you're
doing right now we all stood around
making bad plans that went nowhere yes
but if you thought of using a 10-pack oh
the one thing that could easily get us
out of here yes
they're all over the place right guys
did you still have one what about
causing a nexus event
we're done talking let's go just do what
you want i guess
[Music]
man that sounds like a rough way to live
it's another theme for
loki's you had a child command you
you did well to respect the boy this is
his kingdom
right what was your nexus event your
majesty i killed ball
oh damn
i don't think that loki gonna like that
piece of news nope
[Music]
peter jackson's loki
thanos
wow it's a it's a very attacking
helicopter versus a helicopter it's a
really great helicopter
i am
[Music]
miss minutes i need you to remote access
a series of restricted files from the
archives
what the beginning of time the founding
of the tva
right away wait what about the end of
time it would be impossible to start a
nexus event there
that's it that's the only place they
could be so how do we get past the void
it's impossible there's nothing for the
tempo to lock onto no destination
then we go through it nice that's
suicide
and i guess my need for you has passed
wait
what about the void spacecraft yes
the prototype great oh i'll get the file
super easy
barely an inconvenience maybe she's
working with miss minutes theory
confirmed
miss minutes where are the files on this
time craft it's highly restricted i
might not even have clearance oh no i
think you would
how long any second now go go go
yeah philby sooner or later we'll catch
you
oh you look afraid though i'll admit you
had me fooled there for a minute
i was never fooled i was hoping you come
out with your hands up and i'll put you
in a time loop
you can live out your days in a good
memory do you have any good memories
just won't really the postman she's
dating
yeah it's a green light at the other
side of the pond
[Music]
she's dead too
baller moves sylvie so
after i vanquished captain america and
iron man i claim my prize
all six infinity stones
and saying liar well at least my nexus
event wasn't eating the wrong neighbor's
cat
hey he'd be nice that alligator
polybius it's just i've been wondering
thanos kills this after ragnarok thanos
my timeline everything proceeded
correctly
my entire life until thanos attacked our
ship
i cast a projection of myself so real
even the mad titan believed it hmm
after i faked death i simply drifted in
space
i thought about the universe and my
place in it landed on a remote planet
and stay there in isolation
in solitude for a long long time how did
the tva find you i got lonely but as
soon as i took my first steps to getting
off the planet
the tva arrived oh because we my friends
have but one part to play
the god of outcasts
god about casts
that guy's a good actor who would have
thought where did they find him
you should work for her have any of you
met a woman variant of us sounds
terrifying
she's not trying to take over the tv
she's trying to take it down
and she needs me
it's what keeps us here got to vanquish
a liar
and i could use all the help i could get
[Laughter]
monsters this loki is different
oh i told you which one of us are you
this is a nightmare
okay so it is a very cool
i really want to see if my prediction of
how the events go
go exactly how's that predicted for you
all the way
[Music]
no
no
look at that like the smoke sounds yeah
sylvie are you like getting inside his
mind
oh silvia's gonna be the key to getting
out of here mobius
that's gotta be mobius happy mobius
it's gotta be him
time you can you shut the door
yes by the way you should be careful
just jumping into a stranger's car like
that
oh they edited her out of the shot yeah
oh great
not in egypt anymore i like the music
for him i betrayed you
and now i'm king about that
if you call me serious come on how about
this one my army
my throne about that
beef-witted half-face scrubs we had a d
i love this so much
[Music]
yes
this is how i go down with loki's yeah
oh nice
that is some good sorcerer yeah
[Music]
love the music nothing can change until
the tva is stopped i believe she's our
only chance of stopping the tva
that's good enough for me all right then
okay
got a team we'll get you to it but
that's as far as we go
i just love like all these other people
who are coming here
[Music]
doesn't eldridge mean like dead things
he'll go after the big meal first and
while he's busy with that
we can sneak around the back and uh
stick around the back
wow cheaper wow
what a nightmare
what else what else wow
there's no way you could beat that is
what the show is convinced view
no this is where they all die
how did you with what you could do with
some backup
guys you jive
so you're all after the giant cloud
monster too then we haven't decided how
we're gonna kill it
sorry come again kill it oh my god that
was your plan
yeah and you all went along with it i
was having my dad
what's your plan then i think the person
we're after is beyond the void at the
end of time
and if they are that thing is just their
guard dog predicting the only way in
hmm um how do we get past the guard dog
i'm going to enchant it all right
it's good i've been down here a bit
longer than you i'm going
to do a bit
10 minutes
kang conker are you in here
[Laughter]
immortus
[Music]
not cool what exactly do you want from
me
i want you to tell me what drives her
revenge drives her
killing the time keeper but they turned
out to be fake in case you forgot
so she'll be searching for whoever
created them look how the red and
her eyes are it's like it's crazy it's a
great reflection
i'll never find them not before she does
and why is that you only want it
she needs it
there is a difference she's so good dude
i know her she is incredible
that as well i had to see it on both of
us oh yeah
grin wit you do get back to the tva
what exactly are you getting yourself
into no no
i like to let people know the truth so
just like that you're turning on the
very thing you diverted your life to
it's never too late to change just can't
handle jet ski
all he wants but the fans right now he
cares about you
i i care about you it's cold
nice comes one for you if you like tell
you what you could conjure me a new
outfit
i can't do that it's beyond my skill
level
i didn't have friends
i don't have anyone well you there are
more important things
right right yeah like like bringing down
the tva
i mean saving the universe when you
think about it well there's no need to
be dramatic but yeah
kinda
[Music]
oh loki cuddles it's not very snuggly
okay is it a tablecloth no it's a
blanket
oh you should make it a weighted blanket
oh yeah
oh what a beautiful shot how do i know
that in the final moments you won't
betray me
i betrayed everyone who ever loved me
and that's not who i am anymore
what are you doing this is all over i
don't know i don't know either
maybe we could figure it out
together maybe
what the i did not know this side with
her heads before yes
little floating orb heads
loki's in the mobius
when it hit me earlier i linked to it
i can enchant it and it's gonna take me
to whoever's behind all of this
stan lee i'm staying
lucky i don't even know if this is gonna
work you go
i go man he's really given his whole
heart to her
you boys want to get out of here what no
we're staying here this is our home
looks like you got away in the end
i always do well
see you later loki
hug him yeah yeah
i love them together friends
[Music]
[Laughter]
the scale on this episode yeah i love
that they shoot so much of this in like
these
landscapes wow
purple marvel loves their purple
[Music]
oh didn't even need any words
oh
oh no oh no
oh no
[Music]
wow loki sorcery he's doing asgard
drop that dagger right now it's holding
you back
awesome how beautiful
wow wow we're a badass moment gorgeous
yes
[Music]
oh
wow wow
[Laughter]
stop teasing me
oh
no come on other loki's step up glorious
purpose
so that was not a projection okay
[Music]
oh gorgeous
wow i'm i'm enchanted by this absolutely
now that they've won the
light reflects all green upon them yeah
and green is the complement of purple
they're opposites
[Music]
no red awesome
way to go show god man
that was something that was that was
huh i'm trying to find the right word
right now
a little speechless i'm very oh yeah i
was i was entranced in that i was like
lost in it
i was just like not like there was a
long program like my eyes
are not leaving the screen i'm so into
this
got a couple of little gripes and within
the first half of the episode
okay but for the most part like
well let's make sure to focus in on that
what i really want is dad i want to
talk great about this episode but i want
all the top comments to be
just a couple little little tiny gripes
that don't really
that's what we want you to take away
from something like this you know
you don't need us to tell you what was
amazing about it i've never seen a show
like this
no it really did have like a fantasy
sci-fi arthurian tale about it didn't it
yeah absolutely well and i mean with
richard e grant you get that like
shakespearean like classical bravado too
that was great here really anchors they
were like
richard he grant we need to do some [ __ ]
with him yeah we need to let him do his
thing
just like this
it's like one plot of this episode was
like
um fantasy apocalyptic quest
and then the other side was sci-fi
investigative i was getting something
like ex
machinava for some reason yeah alex
garland
in a few different points especially
with like b15s in in
the jail yeah well and even parts of uh
there's no post-credits scene ah they're
just gonna save it all for the finale
oh wow and something about eliath kind
of took me to uh
in a in a not as directive a way but
kind of to like uh
annihilation a little bit oh yeah yeah i
get what you're saying
so you were not thinking of um
[Music]
the uh i wasn't thinking of the beach
with leonardo dicaprio oh
okay all right because my mind was
actually thinking about
the aladdin one mm-hmm oh yeah
i thought that the first time yeah i was
considering making the joke
i'm glad you stopped considering that
let's talk about this
all right guys so yeah i think it's
actually um like king loki
i think i don't think it's king the
conqueror
um we're actually just on cosmic wonders
live stream before the episode
aired and on there we were saying why we
think narratively because i know last
week we were like it's gotta be king
but as more thought was put into it
before this episode even aired we were
like
no it's probably another loki because
narratively that would make sense
the most with the theme of the show just
being about self-confrontation
yeah and you know how this loki
i want to address something super quick
here as i know that there's this
portion of the internet that's like uh
loki they just they softened him and
they made him a full-blown hero you know
soy
such a protagonist now such a good
person
at this point that he's arrived at in
this show the arc that he has gone
through yeah
and i'm like guys they didn't change
the loki that you were invested in who
was a villain
turned good died at the grip of thanos
that's a different
loki point is that that's difficult
that's a different thing
that one is supposed to exist yes this
is a different loki that we're following
so it's just a different journey for
this
for this uh specific rendition this
variant so to speak
but anyway yeah narratively speaking
because i think the big debate is like
would it be another loki
would it be i don't think it's miss
minutes uh who would it be
um the king the conqueror and what where
i'm sort of coming from is that
from like i think if you're like really
invested in the comics and you read all
that or you watch the breakdowns and
easter eggs and
whatever uh from like other channels
you're it's
you would look at the clue similar to
how we did with mephisto
of like there's agatha harkness in here
devil in the details
um tommy billy and tommy the dark hole
things that were very mephisto tied in
so a lot of us were thinking
it's got to be mephisto right and then
by the time you got to the uh
but then it was like would be kind of
weird to introduce mephisto just in the
final moments
and here i would kind of say the same
thing i think
narratively story structure wise it
would just be more impactful
if it was another loki like you see the
castle here
my mind is going to that shot in the
trailer
of when you do see loki like uh
king of the throne yeah i don't we have
not seen that shot in this show yet
no and i mean we've seen shots in the
trailers that have been altered like you
pointed out with mobius in the car
but yeah not anything yet that just
hasn't been
at all paid off exactly yeah so
i think story wise i get why people
would go to king
i was because i'm like yeah this the
other comics can conquer that that makes
sense and who became conqueror
but then i'm like well we got one
episode left it'd be kind of jarring to
just like
narratively that wouldn't feel
ultimately fulfilling you got to think
about like the general audience all the
people who'd
this is designed for that to experience
this season alone
and from a story person it's like how
can an audience member
who's not familiar with any of that is
just watching the show and has only seen
the movies just watching the show just
go
i'm guessing it's king conqueror hey
usually a big reveal that they've been
setting up like a big reveal that they
have
that a show is setting up generally
speaking it has to be something where an
audience member
can go should have seen that coming you
know yeah and the thing that this
is slowly teaching me and we'll see how
loki winds up but
i think that they are setting up both
kang and mephisto and all these things
and i mean you know looking at falcon
and winter soldier
and and the other uh you know recent
properties like oh the young avengers
are coming the thunderbolts are coming
they're doing a lot of like
long term setups i think but also yeah
with these shows story arcs they're not
making it so it's like you think back to
the original phases and it's like they
built things
way far in advance and i can kind of see
them doing that now with
these characters like kangaroo we know
kang is coming confirmed in at least
ant-man quantomania and so
yeah like the seeds are there and i
think that you know for comic book fans
are for people who are liable to dig in
yeah like i think
the point is to sow those seeds but yeah
i think you're absolutely right like in
a narrative
fashion it's not gonna be fulfilling
emotionally
to have a completely random very powered
up
yeah also you know the blue and purple
guy you know
show up and be like haha it's me like i
wouldn't say it won't be fulfilling but
i i can't imagine it can be as
fulfilling
just when you're speaking from a story
perspective and i feel like that's kind
of where the show is headed while
there's things that are kind of nodding
to king to conquer
and yeah there's no denying it like
whatever they're doing here in loki
is gonna have ramifications for doctor
strange spider-man
no way home um you know ant-man like
it's
king the conqueror for sure is coming
but yeah i think there's a lot of solid
reasons why it wouldn't be king the
conqueror or why i think it would be
another loki and i mean yeah if you
think about it like loki being the
the person at the end of all this really
does fall in line with like the ideal of
his glorious purpose to begin
with like it's the most diabolical he
won he created the time for his
authority and controls all of his
time yeah you know and that would be a
great confrontation
yeah for sylvia and loki and and again
as a self-confrontation
like that would be the kind of piece the
resistance for that
kind of plot line and i think it would
be neat too if because
because we have turned this version of
loki and the character that we have
focused on into
more of a heroic nature like his arc in
this show
it would be cool that if you have a hero
loki and then the big baddie is actually
a villainous
yeah people look like an hour yeah yeah
the most
the the superior loki yeah yeah
oh good call yeah because you can
imagine that line of like i
am the superior and clearly he would
have a lot to back down with him
his accomplishments because that line
did stand out to me of like you're
looking at this planet
i'm like why does it feel like it's just
mainly loki's here
there's so many loki's here i'm like why
are we bumping into the loki's just
traveling backs are there other people
here
or is it just everyone else is pretty
bad at avoiding
the lion and loki's are pretty good at
it
i mean yeah that's just one because they
survive right yeah
um but that that's just one thing to get
out of the way as in in terms of like
the episode itself i thought it was
really well handled
like the the the the
there was like this lord of the
rings-esque fantasy
way this was captured like it's like
adventure quest on foot a lot of those
shots that you have when they're at this
planet yet
um when you go back to the tva it
yeah it's like such a i'm kind of uh
a lot of loss for words when it comes to
describing the
emotional experience of this episode
because it was
it was so varied there was so much
happening in terms of
emotions it it kind of uh
it wowed me in in a different way
well yeah because it gives you like they
are
it's funny to me because they're
constantly surprising
me with how much they're willing to go
with
their emotional residence and how much
they
resonance and how much they want to
deconstruct and like even
throwing fun sci-fi stuff at you like a
bunch of other loki's
and even the way in this episode that
that kind of plays humorously even so
like that's
still every loki he comes in contact
with has to be sort of peeling back
layers and further proving all these
different points he's been learning
about like intentionality and and what
you you know really want to make out of
your life once you've
kind of found your place in the world
and i loved
like getting to hear classic loki's
story because this is a loki who like
became one with the universe and like
went to be dr manhattan
like out in the middle of nowhere and
and yeah like there is
it's almost as if his story was a theory
that we had of how loki could have
survived
avengers infinity war he hides as a
piece of debris
and then yeah and i think like
there is again yes so much like sci-fi
hijinks and
fun to this but again they let kind of
every version
of the character have some kind of at
least the ones we spend the most time
with
characters like even alligator thor is
praying at one point and kid loki
for as much as that's not like a heavy
character he's like i killed thor and
that is a moment
yeah you know on loki and then you have
everything with him and sylvia so like
yeah
there is this like weirdly broad
emotional
spectrum mixed with this also level of
and i think it's not a coincidence that
you see asgard resurrected because
yeah you have this lord of the rings
scale epicness which i feel like what
they always wanted the thor films to
have
and that was some people would argue
kind of a weight
on the first two films keeping them from
being all the much fun as they could be
and i thought this brought the best of
those flavors also into yeah this
big sprawling desolate place at the end
of time that needs to feel epic
and uncharted and unruly you know
speaking of uncharted i kind of felt
like when tom hiddleston suited up
with the sword i was like hey you could
have maybe it wasn't nathan drake and
you
oh yeah yeah you see that and then you
go watch kong skull island and you're
like yeah yeah
yeah he could have done it maybe maybe
there's a possibility they just bulked
up a little bit more and they made him
look shorter
i will say though the the the i like the
last half a lot more there was there was
things
in the first half that i was a little
bit let down by
[Music]
some of it i feel like is valid
criticism other parts are nitpick and
another issue
is just expectation okay um and i think
that falls on the fact that
in the trailers you see the president
loki and that was such a big hyped-up
thing like that even marvel
themselves seem to be pushing that
specific image
of them and then with the t's of oh
you're on a planet where there's going
to be other loki variants to come into
contact with
i felt like they didn't really utilize
or do as much as they could have done
whether that be actual deconstruction
with all the other loki's
and how this can reflect onto the loki
that we're watching
or just having fun with all these loki's
you know like they focused on a few
which is arguably what you ought to do
so you don't get bombarded
really the only way i could have gotten
my wish fulfilled is if this episode
or like focusing on this planet if they
had made it into two episodes
which i really wouldn't have minded
because i wanted to kind of live
in here a little bit longer in the
isolation
in the desolation really get into the
shoes of what it would be like
really sell me or at least attempt to
sell me
on how's loki going to get out of here
because pretty
quick into it you know sylvie prunes
herself
lands on the planet and uh and then
shortly after that sylvie mobius
fine loki yeah all right let's start
solving the day that's our saving the
day because sylvia's got this kind of
figured out on
on a plan and ideas of what they can
ultimately do right
i really thought in the last half we
started getting some great you know
emotional nuance
uh even in the scenes with loki and
sophie like that especially
yeah uh i i love like the the way that's
played because
it's the whole scene is them they're
saying something else to each other the
entire time
then what's actually coming out of their
mouths at that moment
so i i love like that kind of cutesy
romancing a lot of people are like no
it's just friends you know the director
came out and said that it
there's no romantic inkling i'm like
well man that guy that was so intimate
this is so it was so intimate and so
like i'm giving you my soul silver yeah
i am who i am today because you really
changed i'm not gonna risk my
life to the end of time if you go i go
i'm talking in the poetic nature and how
he spoke
like i know it's not he hasn't
completely changed only because of her
yeah there's a whole bunch of experience
that have happened from right down from
the first episode of seeing how his
timeline should have played out learning
about reality
his interaction with moby there's a lot
the paperweights there's a lot of whitey
changed
his reality has been shattered and he's
been forced to reflect and look at
himself and who he became i i get that
i'm just saying in the way he talks with
her for right up into that scene where
he's creating the blanket
moving forward almost like he just keeps
pausing to be like
i trust you with everything
right yeah i would i wouldn't know
everyone would be a father heartbeat
like every he just kept pausing yes
they're like
i'm gonna be so so good to you right now
i'm gonna be so trustworthy yeah so i
i i really appreciate that i did feel
like oh man but you like tease the
present like i love the setup
of what they even did with oh you got
some of these
loner loki's kid loki classic loki oh
but then there's like this president of
loki and these like viking
like barbaric loki's here like there's a
there's a story here to unpack
and it kind of just went by and really
quick and i think that does fall on the
expectation problem because
marvel really pushed it obviously
learning more about it from watching
like breakdowns and easter eggs are like
what president loki is and
and i just felt that if you're going to
go to this planet there's other loki
variants there's so much you can do i
was kind of wanting a little bit of
cinderella
yeah yeah absolutely you want your like
rolling door of all the different
possibilities at least a little bit even
in a month
i feel like this is going to be one of
my gripes for the mcu shows i can
already
i'm getting the inkling it's like the
netflix shows the gripe quickly became
man if they just paired this down by a
couple episodes
and now with these mcu shows i'm like
man if they just added one or two more
episodes
to let a couple more things breathe
because yeah like
i i don't hold it necessarily against
this episode but i do feel like there
were a lot of opportunities to expand on
some things and also let a couple other
things breathe because like we could
have
not that i don't know if we absolutely
needed it but you know i would have been
interested in finding out like how did
moebius find himself in this place
and you know make it to the point where
he could find sylvie
and help her out and kind of orient
himself or whatever
um yeah because he finds like silvia
shows up there seemed to be a lot of
fortunate convenience a lot of good
timings
for them that i thought they could have
lived a little bit longer
in the hopelessness yeah and they don't
really do that when i'm like but you're
on a planet that just
you know is calling for that level of
storytelling
so you can really feel more of the
heroic triumph too
of like i love that classy classic loki
moment when he
gets involved in the enchantment
building the asgard you're seeing like
damn his
the loki sorcery that he was teasing and
his projection ability truly
is powerful inspiring yeah it's gorgeous
to look at and it's a great
moment so very triumphant um
and i and i can't help but feel like oh
but can you imagine if we just
lived in their shoes longer like how
much how much more that moment could
have
hit yeah the funny thing is right now
i'm like this might be
you know and obviously it's the
afterglow of the immediate experience
but i'm like this might be my favorite
episode so far i love this but at the
same time now i'm imagining a version
where the
back and forth between sylvia and
renslayer went for most of the episode
and it ends with her pruning herself
and we spend most of this time just
exploring
yeah this whole other alternate ver loki
you know trash can universe
because they like they literally lead
you on ravona for like a tiny bit not
enough
for me to even i was like barely even
swaying to oh maybe she's still i'm like
no i don't like i don't bite us at all
the only nugget of truth and i
appreciate it very much i
do because i buy this could be the case
that she
does feel sort of bewildered and
betrayed not knowing exactly what's
going on i could fathom that and i
i'm happy hopefully that that is a part
of it
but yeah it's like i i never fully
believed her although i thought their
interplay just as performers was
fantastic
yeah so she sold it really well i still
like the scenes yeah absolutely i still
liked like there wasn't a scene here i
didn't
actually like yeah there was just more
stuff i wish they had
sort of just you know let percolate more
hurt
yeah dive in deeper uh but you know
that's the problem with
like i get what they're doing with the
show so
yeah i mean with ravona there's some
interesting things they do bring up
about her because they're like what is
driving her
b15 says directly to her sylvie needs
you want and she has a line to miss
minutes where she does
say that whoever created all this is in
trouble
yeah we need to protect them and she
does kind of have this like
marshall that that marshall [ __ ] like
cowboy
thing about her like i'm next in charge
it's up to me to figure all this out and
if i do
they're going to be real happy with me
like i need to i still
uphold my my stance and i'm still
yeah i'm still loyal uh i just need to
know and protect him but cpa needs
stability
yes so like she still believes that kind
of in this weird cause when she wants to
know who's in conjunction i really
believe she doesn't know who's in
control
obviously because especially the way how
she was questioning b15 or perhaps it
was
just uh like i want to see if she b15
actually knows anything if i have to
prune her or some [ __ ] right yeah
yeah yeah so like in in the last half of
this episode i really thought what the
with a big payoff to me was like yes the
sweeping finale
of all this and uh like mobius reuniting
like that goodbye moment i thought was
pretty great they've got some great
relate like and
even if loki and sylvie aren't
romantically inclined like i really do
love that between loki and silby and
loki and mobius they created
two like really endearing authentic
feeling
connections friendships whatever you
want to call it yeah
so yeah like it was almost a joke during
the reaction i was like ah go ahead hug
him
but like it really read as like no like
bring it in like
thank you loki tha that's a physical
representation because look
look he's not that kind of guy generally
yeah you know what no
screw the handshake let's hug you know
yeah like it's a trope of a moment
um but at the same time to pl
apply it to this not just this dynamic
but to this
character loki that is like he wouldn't
do that before
no and and i think it's a beautiful way
to show like yeah we've been in the same
shoes and now
it's your turn to be plucked from your
timeline and told that your whole
universe is upside down and you're
living out somebody else's divine
purpose you know
yeah i loved owen wilson's performance
and here i loved all their performances
richard e grant was a big highlight to
me
i did like seeing tom hiddleston briefly
play president loki or at least the
you know i know the the costume
represents it more i don't think i don't
know if the characters call president
loki
uh but he does have this like a little
bit more gravity like yeah a little more
sleazy politician version
yeah i like that a lot that he yeah he
he still did something different
with it um more than just changed like
there was something about his mannerisms
and body language he made sure that even
though
he shares the same face he would he
would portray in a way that feels very
distinct
yeah yeah and so i thought that was
grand and uh yeah there's like fun stuff
in here with like the thanos copter
there's a bunch of things frog yeah
there's near
the little thor yeah yeah it's a little
thor right it's throgg i think right
that was throg i think so yeah yeah i
couldn't tell that was a little thor
throg yeah it was like so quick but he
looked
like spindly in building oh man so i
assumed it was maybe
a throg in there okay yeah i don't know
like yeah something about the design
seemed like it was not quite humanoid
it was like a tiny little capture but
it's got to be throgged i mean
that also exists you know it does
either way i thought that was like a fun
version of that
um on that then maybe that torpedo is
also a thing
that's right next to the thing there is
a line in there that loki says
the president loki looking one of like
where we prefer snakes to wolves
yeah which is like a fun ragnarok
reference
and also like how that story of messing
with uh thor
about the snakes you know oh they're
things they're things i kind of pick up
on but most things i'll probably miss i
liked alligator loki
i liked him a lot i hope he gets a spin
off i enjoyed this episode quite a bit
it wasn't personally my favorite one um
but it had some of my favorite
moments fair it's 100
fair uh yeah powerful stuff all right
i'm going to look at this shot really
quick
do it moment of truth let's brighten
this memento
this video is over very toss those
different languages so many cafe
cafeteria trays from spider-man
obviously
yes oh was throg yeah
nice oh damn
okay all right cool i'm gonna make sure
to tell for a thumb
to throw a text in there yeah sweet
good catch all right guys well um thank
you so much for being here
if you enjoyed our video make sure to
subscribe and click that bell hit that
like button
and uh leave your thoughts down below
correct us on anything you want
or leave your theories whatever tell us
all we missed last not least let's do it
mchale linden mchale this is a
no-brainer for me
because if there's anybody at our
patreon i could imagine
as a variant loki it's you
because think about it man you've
already got the sort of nordic
scandinavian roots there from where
you're from
but also i can imagine you as a totally
awesome
variant that's like james bond themed
because that's
your passion in life all right that's
what you're dedicated to above all else
your glorious
purpose is espionage mikhail
i hope you're enjoying the show i hope
that you are
well and uh i hope that by the final
episode we
see that it's actually you who's uh king
loki at the end of all time in space
with eric horseman i did the same bit
about how that is a he's a variant loki
of who is there anyone i can imagine
being a variant
he's also a good loki but but mikhail
would be a more sinister loki
you've got dane cookman
[Laughter]
hey i came to do it on my own
jokes are similar it happens man come on